so it's before I get started I'm really
excited to be here actually to just
actually watch what's going to happen
from here so with that said right we're
gonna start with what is one of our
greatest needs one of our greatest needs
for our brain and instead of telling you
I want to show you in fact I want you to
feel it there's a lot I want you to feel
in the next 14 minutes so if we can all
stand up right we're all going to
conduct a piece of Strauss together all
right and you all know it all right are
you ready all right ready 1 2 3
it's just the end
[Music]
right you know where it's going
oh it's coming
oh great collective coitus interruptus
okay you can all sit down we have a
fundamental need for closure wait we
love closure when I always told the
story that when Mozart when he would go
just before you go to bed he'd go to the
piano go dah dah dah dah dah his father
who was already in bed think ah he'd
have to get up and hit the final note of
the chord before he go back to sleep
okay so the need for closure leads us to
thinking about what is our greatest fear
I think what is our greatest fear
growing up even now and it's the fear of
the dark we hate uncertainty we hate to
not know we hate it think about horror
films horror films always shot in the
dark right in the forest at night in the
depths of the sea the blackness of space
right and the reason is because dying
was easy during revolution right if you
weren't sure that was a predator it was
too late your brain evolved to predict
and if you couldn't predict you died and
the way your brain predicts is by
encoding
the bias and assumptions that were
useful in the past but those assumptions
just don't stay inside your brain you
project them out into the world
there is no bird there you're projecting
the meaning onto the screen everything
I'm saying to you right now is literally
meaningless you're creating the meaning
and projecting it onto me and what's
true for objects is true for other
people while you can measure their what
in the wind you can never measure their
why so we color the people when you
project a meaning onto them based on our
biases in our experience which is why
the best of design is almost always
about decreasing uncertainty
so when we step in towards certainty our
bodies respond physiologically and
mentally right your immune system will
start deteriorating your brain cells
wither and even die you your creativity
and intelligence decrease we often go
from fear to anger almost too often
why because fear is a state of certainty
you become morally judgemental you
become an extreme version of yourself if
your conservative you become more
conservative if you're a liberal you
become more liberal because you go to a
place of familiarity
the problem is that the world changes
and we have to adapt or die and if you
want to shift from A to B the first step
is not be the first step is to go from a
- not a - let go of your biases
assumptions to step into the very place
that our brain evolved to avoid to step
into the place of the unknown but it's
so essential that we go to this place
that our brain gave us a solution
evolution gave us a solution and is
possibly one of the most profound
perceptual experiences and it's the
experience of all
[Music]
[Applause]
ah how wonderful right so right now
you're probably all feeling at some
level or another all right so what's
happening inside your brain right now
right and for thousands of years we've
been thinking and writing and
experiencing all and we know so little
about it and so to try to understand
what is it and what does it do my lab of
misfits had just the wonderful
opportunity in the pleasure to work with
who are some of the greatest creators of
all that we know the writers the
creators the directors the accountants
the people who are Cirque du Soleil
okay and so we went to Las Vegas and we
recorded the brain activity of people
while they're watching the performance
over ten performances of Oh which is
iconic circuit performance and we also
measured the behavior before the
performance as well as a different group
after the performance and so we had over
a few hundred people involved so what is
all what is happening inside your brain
right now it's a brain state okay
the front part of your brain the
prefrontal cortex which was responsible
for your executive function your
attentional control is now being down
regulated the parts of your brain called
the DMM the default mode network which
is the interaction between multiple
areas in your brain which is active
during sort of ideation creative
thinking in terms of divergent thinking
and daydreaming is now being upregulated
and right about now the activity in your
prefrontal cortex is changing is
becoming asymmetrical in its activity
biased towards the right which is higher
correlated when when people step forward
into the world as opposed to step back
in fact the activity across the brains
of all these people is so cool
related that were able to train an
artificial neural network to predict
whether or not people are experiencing
all to an accuracy of 75% on average
with a maximum of 83% so what does this
brain state do right well others have
demonstrated for instance professor
heightened Keltner have told us that
people feel small but connected to the
world and they're pro-social behavior
increases because they feel an increased
affinity towards others and we've also
shown in this study that people have a
less need for cognitive control they're
more comfortable with uncertainty
without having closure and their
appetite for risk also increases they
actually seek risk and there are better
able at taking it and something that was
really quite profound is that when we
ask people are you someone who has
propensity to experience are they were
more likely to give a positive response
after the performance than they were
they literally redefine themselves and
their history so ah is possibly the
perception that is bigger than us and in
the words of Joseph Campbell ah is what
enables us to move forward or in the
words of a dear friend probably one of
our greatest photographers to live in
photographers Dwayne Michaels he said to
me just the other day that maybe it
gives us the curiosity to overcome our
cowardice so who cares why should we
care well consider conflict which seems
to be so omnipresent in our society at
the moment if you aren't iron conflict
it's as if we're at the opposite ends in
the same line and my aim is to prove
that you're wrong to shift you towards
me the problem is you're doing exactly
the same you're trying to prove that I'm
wrong and shift me towards you
right notice that conflict is to set up
to win but not learn your brain only
learns if we move life is movement
so what if we could use all not to get
rid of conflict conflict is essential
conflict is how your brain expands is
how your brain learns but rather to
enter conflict in a different way and
what if we could enter it all could
enable us to enter it in at least two
different ways one to give us the
humility and courage to not know right
to enter conflict with a question
instead of an answer what would happen
then to enter the conflict with
uncertainty instead of certainly and the
second is an entering conflict that way
to seek to understand rather than
convince right because everyone makes
sense to themselves right and to
understand another person is to
understand the biases and assumptions
that give rise to their behavior and
we've actually initiated a pilot study
to look to see whether we could use art
induced or to facilitate toleration and
the results are actually incredibly
positive we can mitigate against anger
and hate through the experience of are
generated by art so where can we find or
given how important it is so what if a
suggestion that are is not just to be
found in the grandeur right all as
essential often its scale right the
mountains the Sun scape right but what
if we could actually rescale ourselves
right and find the impossible in the
simple and if this is true and our data
are right then endeavors like science
adventure art ideas love a TED
Conference performance are not only
inspired by all but could actually be
our ladders into uncertainty to help us
spend
thank you very much please come up